right now
jorge lopez is on the rubber ready to
work
against jorge polanco as the orioles and
the twins
meeting up for the second time in as
many weeks last week minnesota took
three games in a row against the orioles
jorge lopez though turned in a quality
start
and down he goes so an opening strikeout
here
for lopez one down yeah back-to-back
change-ups through the fastball by him
that'll speed the bat up kind of the art
of pitching with one down donaldson
stands in
and a deep drive to left to the corner
stewart chasing it and off the wall
and donaldson rounds first heads to
second just missing a home run
fastball tailing up and in and he was
ready for it not a fastball was able to
turn on it just a home run by about a
foot he's at second with one down
that'll bring up alex caroline lopez
ahead a ball and two strikes
got him
second strike out of the inning two down
well there's no doubt about it jorge
lopez i mean stuff wise yeah you know we
already saw a change up we've already
seen 96 and here's the
shoe top drop the curve ball
donaldson on second two down cruz looper
right to short veleka will take care of
that and the one out double goes by the
boards after a half it's minnesota
nothing the orioles coming to bat
against jose barrios yeah jose barreos
from puerto rico you can pitch a little
bit
go all the way back 2017 only justin
bertland with more wins he's got 50
justin with 53.
real good curveball
you know moving fastball was running all
over the place
it will right field
won't catch up to that one bounces off
the 373 sign and cedric
in with a stand-up double to start
things off yeah he was thinking triple
though and this is what he brings and
that ball belted
so cedric mullins smacked that one over
the head of alex kirill off in right
field trying to find a way to get a run
home against a really tough pitcher 2-1
pitch broken back grounder to the mound
it won't happen here barrios flips it
onto first base you get the lead off man
at second and you don't score isaiah
will shake that right hand out franco is
going to do the same orioles squadron
lead off double league one after one no
score
garlic with a base hit to center
and the lead off man is on and he'll
hold up with a single and that'll get
simmons to the play
and garlic off with the pitch and he'll
steal a base
on simmons check swing and wins didn't
even effort a throw
simmons dribbles one near the mound
there's nobody at third base and simmons
is safe
lopez looked at third but the third
baseman franco was converging on the
chopper so there was nobody there and
that little hesitation cost him an out
at first base
so now in a nothing nothing game top of
the order for jorge polanco and runners
on at the corners
ground ball hit towards second out at
second
safe at first and the run scores
garlic comes in from third the twins
take the first lead
and polanco getting credit for a run
batted in start things off in the top of
the fourth one nothing minnesota ground
ball the dive the lake up with it and
gets the out pretty play i want balaka
playing the
kind of middle infielder there because
he's
a shortstop playing on the right side in
the shift he hasn't gotten a lot of time
at shortstop this year this is just the
fourth game that he has played in short
this season but anne valencia did a good
job to get jorge lopez and out you know
comes out of your hand you know
brielle's he's a high velocity guy he
does pitch inside shakes off about twice
on garver and now
ready to go and the pitch is ground ball
fielded by simmons it's short
and on target throw to retire
franco three up three down nice job for
jose barrios
through four camden yards it's one
nothing minnesota
bouncer to third franco busy down there
two down
well that's your two-seam fastball you
want to get some easy outs it's nice to
strike people out takes more pitches
usually
two seamer a couple of grounders so it
shifts the runner into scoring position
the next pitch polancos swings pops it
up valenca out
shading his eyes from the sun with his
glove he staggers back a step and makes
the catch 13 in a row
set down by the orioles to trail the
twins one nothing in the bottom half of
the fifth inning and the quality of the
bats just have not been good against
jose barrios the 1-1 pitch mount castle
belts it to center field ref snyder back
he's on the track he's at the wall he
runs into the wall and it's over the
wall
ryan mount castle ties the game up at
one in the fifth inning
ref snyder thunding up against the fence
realizing he was out of room as mel
castle ties this game up at one maybe
it's going to be mount castle who's
gonna come on for now he's tied the game
up in one he's he doesn't know where he
is and wham that had to hurt franco for
two
got him batting in the fourth spot for a
reason he does have 25 ribbies veteran
and a groud ball that's going to be
fielded by donaldson
across the diamond as funko
grounds out on the first pitch threat by
baltimore they strand two through six
one one tie
all tied one to one jose has never lost
a decision to baltimore and the one-two
pitch he got him strike three in a
breaking ball so barrio strikes out
wilkerson for the second time today and
now five strikeouts as he works through
seven oh it's two balls and two strikes
against nelson cruz
even count against the powerful right
hand batter the 2-2
slider he got him tanner scott strikes
out nelson cruz who has caved three
times in this game the go ahead run kept
on base at first and we'll move to the
bottom of the eighth rios struck out
five no walks in a 1-1 game base is
empty nobody out shakes off garver twice
and now comes home and the o2 pitcher
ground ball left side sliding stop
donaldson to his feet spins and throws
him out good play
even cino applause the effort from
number 20 across the diamond josh went
low and down to the ground slid to his
left popped up 360 twirl on target throw
two cenote to retire wins for the first
out two outs bottom eight the 3-2 pitch
a swing at a fly ball pop fly
infield near short donaldson has it and
that's the inning the deepest barrios
has gone in a start this season eight
innings in baltimore he has allowed only
one run jose barrios pleaded eight and
he's gonna come out to start the bottom
half of the ninth inning
the looper into center field and it's in
for a base hit
mancini with a lead-off single to get it
started there's your winning run there's
a flare that just got over polanco's
head so that's the end of the day
carrios was very good he was fabulous
simmons with the infield drawn in
that gets away from the catcher
and scoring the go-ahead run as
ref snyder two outs and now polacco in a
2-1 game
and the pitch is swinging a blast into
right field deep back it goes deep it
goes and that ball is called a home run
as polanco finds the plaza in right
field insurance in the 10th and the
twins have a 3-1 lead in baltimore
franco
is going to run at second base to start
the bottom half of the 10th inning
first pitch swinging fly ball left
center field it's in the gap
bronco around third he will score dj
stewart's in with the tying run at
second base pumps his fist
and he got him well the guy that you
need to get out and the gorse the guy
you're hoping they can make contact
[Applause]
and a high fly ball to right field
kirilov under it
and the twins win the opener
they've beaten the orioles for the 16th
straight time